12 Asylum Seekers including men women
children and an infant are forced out of
a van and into a speedboat by masked men
on the Greek Island of Lesbos
the Asylum Seekers are from Somalia
Eritrea and Ethiopia
they're transferred to a Greek Coast
Guard vessel it travels across the
Aegean Sea towards Takia
the Asylum Seekers are then crammed into
a dinghy and left adrift for more than
an hour the footage was filmed by an aid
worker on Lesbos normally when you see a
crime you call the police or you call
the public prosecutor but you cannot do
this increase increase the authorities
are the ones committing these crimes and
of course the orders for these crimes
come from high up like from the Greek
government there is no police to call
because the police are in on this I have
witnessed it myself
the Asylum Seekers were eventually found
by the Turkish Coast Guard they were
taken to a Detention Center in the city
of Izmir Naima Aden and her
six-month-old sonawali were among those
rescued they fled the Somali city of
jalib which is controlled by the armed
group al-shabab The Greek government has
not commented on the allegations but
it's previously denied mistreating
Asylum Seekers
the EU says it's concerned by the
footage it says Greece must fully
respect its obligations to ensure the
safety and well-being of Asylum Seekers
until their case is processed Victoria
gatenby Al Jazeera